un baño de masas
convertido en un balde de agua fría no
fueron saludos para el presidente de la
república fueron pedidos de dimisión y
hasta acusaciones de corrupción es el
sentir que se respira en las calles de
Francia luego de tres meses de protestas
contra la recién promulgada reforma
pensional que eleva la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años
[Música]
sí grité y le dije que pelearemos que
vamos a luchar por poder jubilarnos a
los 60 años y que los franceses como
todos los franceses Seguiremos
expresando nuestro descontento no vamos
a pasar la página sobre esta reforma de
las pensiones
es el primer viaje a las regiones de
macron desde que promulgó el sábado la
reforma pensional texto que sacó
adelante evadiendo el voto de la
asamblea nacional el jefe de estado
eligió visitar la región de alsacia en
el gran este una zona que votó en
mayoría por él en la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales
y normal es normal que se exprese esta
ira Ahí está también hay personas que
tienen otras motivaciones que vinieron a
saludarme otras que me están apoyando
estuvieron conmigo esta mañana en una
empresa que refleja la diversidad de
Francia no escuché ninguna movilización
esta vez para poder salir adelante ir a
las empresas y hacer cosas sin embargo
se nota ese enojo no esperaba otra cosa
pero no me va a impedir seguir
moviéndome por el país porque hay que
seguir actuando y salir adelante
sus principales sindicatos de Francia
han hecho un llamado para una nueva gran
movilización el primero de mayo día
internacional de los trabajadores